>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
OUT IN THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING
CHARLIE MANN JOINS US.
>> THERE'S TWO BIG OUTSTANDING
QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST IS MOTIVE.
WHY DOES A GUY LIKE THIS ENGAGE
IN THE -- ONE OF THE LARGEST
MASS MURDERS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY?
ALTHOUGH THE MOTIVE IS UNCLEAR,
AND I CAN'T CONFIRM ANYTHING, I
THINK THERE'S A HIGH PROBABILITY
THAT LOOKS LIKE SOME FORM OF
RADICALIZATION.
WHAT THAT IS ALWAYS ASSOCIATED
WITH ISLAMIC TERROR.
THAT MAY NOT BE IT.
COULD BE A POLITICAL MOTIVATION
AS WELL.
ONE MORE POINT HERE.
I DON'T THINK THE TARGET
SELECTION WAS RANDOM.
THE FACT THAT IT WAS A COUNTRY
MUSIC CONCERT, THE FACT THAT IT
WAS LAS VEGAS.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS RANDOM.
WHEN THIS COMES OUT IN THE WASH,
IT MAY BE A FACTOR.
THE SECOND POINT.
WAS HE ALONE?
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS HE WAS THE
LONE GUNMAN IN THIS CASE BASED
ON THE EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M ASKING.
WAS HE ALONE OR DID HE HAVE SOME
KIND OF SUPPORT STRUCTURE IN
THIS GETS FLESHED OUT AND WE SEE
THE REPORTS START TO BECOME
PUBLIC, I HAVE A REALLY HARD
TIME BELIEVING THAT IT'S GOING
TO INDICATE THAT HE WAS THE ONLY
PERSON INVOLVED IN THIS.
THERE HAS TO HAVE BEEN SOME
LEVEL OF LOGISTICAL SUPPORT OR
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT IN THIS.
>> Tucker: ONE INDICATION OF
THAT ARE THE E-MAIL ACCOUNTS
THAT HE -- THAT PADDOCK
MAINTAINED THAT WE LEARNED ABOUT
A COUPLE DAYS AGO FROM WHICH HE
SENT E-MAILS FROM ONE TO THE
OTHER.
BASICALLY ADDRESSED TO ANOTHER
PERSON.
THAT PERSON IS NOT NAMED.
BUT HE WAS CLEARLY WRITING TO
SOMEONE ELSE.
THEY WEREN'T JUST NOTES TO
HIMSELF.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> THIS IS VERY BIZARRE, TUCKER
AND BIZARRE SINCE DAY ONE.
E-MAILING HIMSELF, WHICH ADDS TO
THE WHOLE MYSTERY.
THE NEW DEVELOPMENTS IS MARY LOU
DANLEY ADMITTED TO INVESTIGATORS
THAT HER PARENTS WILL BE ON THE
AMMO.
SHE'S IN BIG TROUBLE RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS IN INSTANT REPLAY TO THE
PULSE NIGHTCLUB TRAGEDY WHERE
THE SIGNIFICANT OTHER WILL BE
GOING TO TRIAL IN ORLANDO MARCH
1.
VERY INTERESTING TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS WITH MARY LOU DANLEY,
THE GIRLFRIEND OF MR. PADDOCK.
>> Tucker: SO THE QUESTIONS, DID
FEDERAL OR STATE AUTHORITIES
HAVE ANY KNOWLEDGE AT ALL OF
PADDOCK?
HAD THEY HAD CONTACT WITH HIM?
WERE THEY AWARE OF HIM BEFORE
THE SHOOTING?
DO WE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THAT?
>> NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE.
NO.
THE FBI HAS SAID THAT THEY NOW
SHOOTER, WHICH TO ME IS NOT VERY
REVEALING AND NOT SHOCKING NEWS
TO ANYBODY.
>> Tucker: NO.
ESPECIALLY NOT IN THIS CASE.
SO DO WE HAVE ANY -- I DON'T
WANT YOU TO SPECULATE OR GET
OVER YOUR SKIS AT ALL.
WE DON'T WANT TO MUDDY IT WITH
THINGS WE DON'T KNOW FOR
CERTAIN.
BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY IT'S TAKING
SO LONG TO GET BASIC INFORMATION
OUT OF THIS INVESTIGATION AND
ANY INDICATION AS TO WHY IT
SEEMS TO BE CONDUCTED IN THIS
I ALWAYS APPRECIATE YOU WANTING
TO STICK TO WHAT WE KNOW.
I THINK THAT HELPS.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
UNNECESSARILY CRYPTIC ABOUT
THIS, WHICH IS FOSTERED A BUNCH
OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
TUCKER, THINK ABOUT IT.
JUST FROM PLAIN SPEAK, THERE'S A
SERIOUS ECONOMIC AND FINANCIAL
QUIET FOR A WHILE AND TO KEEP IT
OFF THE FRONT PAGES UNTIL THE
NEWS BLOWS OVER.
>> IT'S NOT OBVIOUS.
IT DOESN'T TAKE A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST TO FIGURE OUT YOU'RE
ONE OF THE MAJOR TOURIST
OF EVERY PAPER FROM NOW TO
PERPETUITY THE FACT THAT YOU
COULD BE SUBJECTED TO SNIPER
FIRE THERE A BUILDING IN THE
LAS VEGAS STRIP.
>> Tucker: BUT THAT'S -- BIG
COMPANIES SHOULD NOT HAVE
INFLUENCE IN CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS.
THAT'S JUSTICE 101.
>> I'M NOT JUSTIFYING IT.
>> Tucker: BUT YOU'RE RIGHT.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON AND I